a 14 días de las elecciones
presidenciales del consejo nacional
electoral proclamó los resultados
oficiales
andrés zarautz y guillermo lasso se
disputarán en segunda vuelta electoral
el 11 de abril ya q pérez quedaría en
tercer lugar en los comicios
presidenciales nos fueron aceptadas sus
solicitudes de abrir las urnas en 100%
en guayas y 50% en 16 provincias del
país solo se aceptó un reconteo parcial
en 26 actas en dos provincias del país
la proclamación se produce en medio de
tensiones entre el órgano comicial la
contraloría y la fiscalía general del
estado que han aprobado para este
domingo un peritaje del sistema
informático electoral la dirigencia se
producirá a partir de las 7 y 30 de la
mañana que ha sido calificada con una
falta grave considerada como una
intervención en medio de un proceso
electoral mientras tanto los principales
candidatos lo han calificado como un
intento de evitar la segunda vuelta
electoral y anular así las elecciones a
presidente del cnt se ha pronunciado ya
exhorta a los principales organismos a
no hacerse eco del juego político para
preservar intereses partidistas